Hey everyone, my name is Eric Hanchett,
and today I want to tell you guys all
about spec-driven development and how
you might use it in your workflows
today. So, there's a couple of things we
want to talk about. First, what is
spec-driven development? And then, how
can it make you a better and faster
coder? So, we just don't want you to
code faster, but we want you to actually
create higher-quality
code from it. And I think really
spec-driven development helps you with
this, and I'm going to explain why and
how. It's a structured specifications
are created before any code is written.
That's the definition of really the
specs or the requirements of this
spec-driven development, and it goes to
the heart of what it is. So, what we're
doing is we are writing these markdown
files, we're writing the specifications
and the design document before any of
the code is written. And this actually
works really, really well with large
language models and our coding
assistants that we use. And I'm going to
show you exactly how that works.
Now, a question I sometimes get is why?
Like, why should we use this spec-driven
development workflow and then how can we
do it? So, to answer that why question,
I kind of like to think about our coding
assistants, our large language models
that we're using every day as sort of
like AI interns. You need to really
prompt them, you really need to push
them the right way, no pun intended with
the prompting. So, you really need to
guide them. Because if you give them
just a little bit of of leeway, they
will go off the rails. And really the
spec-driven development helps guide them
in the right direction. I remember when
I was an intern in one of my first jobs,
we had a VP that would walk around and
he would just come up with random ideas
off the top of his head. And when he
told me it, I would drop everything and
work on it. And then later my boss would
be like, "Hey Eric, why did you drop
everything?" Well, the the VP said
something. And then I learned about,
well, you got to take his information
that he gives you, write it down, put it
in your schedule, talk to me talk to my
manager about it. So, I was a little too
eager. And this is what AI interns or
basically these large language models do
nowadays. And we got to be careful about
it.
I didn't really give you too much of
introduction, so I'll give it to you
now. My name is Eric Hanchett. I'm a
senior developer advocate at AWS. I have
over 15-plus years of software
development experience.
And if you want to connect with me, you
can check out LinkedIn. That's probably
the best place to go.
I just look for Eric Hanchett and yeah,
talk to me, follow me. I'd love to talk
to you more about it.
Another question when I that people
often ask me about spec-driven
development is, "Can't the latest
frontier models just do everything for
us already? Why do we need this?"
And while I do say that the models are
getting better and better every year and
and every release, sometimes
incrementally, sometimes by leaps and
bounds, it's still not perfect. And
giving the large language model these
models more context is actually really
important because it does help guide it
in the right direction. And with our
software
always changing and with the
requirements always changing, and with
new paradigms and shifts, you always
need to kind of guide it
where it needs to go. Some large
language models, some harnesses are
starting to think more about this and
adding in a little bit more of a
thinking or planning mode before it
jumps into when it writes code. But
there's nothing better than actually
having those documents created and
having you be in the middle before it
jumps into the net that next part with
it creating code.
So, let's keep a few things in mind
before we get too far.
There is quite
a lot of information out there. I have
some opinions. These are my opinions.
Uh let me know. Connect with me on
LinkedIn if you agree or disagree, but I
think you need to keep these in mind
before using spec-driven development or
vibe coding or anything in between.
We have to You have to be careful with
context. Now, I told you before that
spec-driven development gives you a lot
of context that gets fed into that large
language model, but sometimes you have
too much of a good thing. Uh what you
need to do is when you are working with
these large language models, usually you
create like an agents.md or claw.md at
the beginning with some information in
it. I would be very careful not to put
too much information or too little
information in that. Kind of like that
Goldilocks zone of information is what
you need. So, you just need to give it
enough
rules and guidelines that it knows what
to do.
Uh we call it steering docs in Cara,
which I'll mention about in a minute,
but you just got to be very careful what
you put in those documents.
I also highly recommend when you're
using spec-driven development to use
skills. Skills are like instruction
files that you can give to your coding
agents that are ran on demand. So,
usually they have keywords in them, and
when the coding assistant sees those
keywords, they'll activate the skill or
you can do  and the skill name
and then run it. But, this actually
really helps when you're doing the
spec-driven development process. You can
actually add skills
um when it creates your design documents
or whatever else. You can use those in
parallel or with the spec-driven
development or when you actually
implement the tasks.
And just be careful about giving too
much trust. Uh
remember everything in the spec-driven
development flow is you, meaning that
you are the human in the loop, so to
speak. You need to be the code reviewer
of all the code that's generated through
this process. You need to be
interactively looking at the design
documents and the requirements documents
that are created because at the end of
the day, if something goes wrong, you
are the person that are going to be
blamed for it, not the agent.
And uh that's not to say that we don't
use tools to help do code reviews.
Someone once told me like, are you
saying you're the human in the loop, you
do the code review, no one else? Of
course, we might have multiple be doing
people doing code reviews and definitely
use your normal AI coding
assistants and and review tools to help
you review any pull request that you
create.
Or
CRs.
So, let me give you a little bit of a
history lesson of where we have been,
especially at AWS.
We uh saw this need, especially from our
teams and our customers, that they were
vibe coding, they were using this coding
assistance, but they weren't getting the
outputs that they wanted. And what we
saw is this these customers were using
this bespoke pattern of having the
agents, the coding assistants, create
uh these full down requirements
documents and these design documents and
we decided to create
a application to kind of do this all for
them. So, we released Qiro uh
early late last year in a general
availability. It's our new AI IDE coding
assistant. We also have a command line
interface or CLI version, which is just
as popular. I think right now
it's switching. Most people are starting
to use CLIs more often than IDEs. So, if
you like to do that, you can use the
CLI.
But, what we really focused in on with
Qiro is, you can see in these
screenshots, is this vibe and spec mode.
So, we're going to jump into spec mode
in a little bit, but we really thought
this really encompass what we were
hearing from our customers, what people
wanted more
ways to work with larger features and
more complex projects and they really
needed the coding system to know exactly
what their project was doing.
We also released the website at
kiro.dev. Feel free to after this
presentation to go check it out. You can
download our CLI, our IDE, and give it a
whirl cuz you know, we're really proud
of it. It's fun. When we released this,
it actually went a little bit viral. We
got tens of thousands of downloads. A
lot of people were asking us asking us
about Kiro so we were really happy to to
release this and we actually
when we set it up in preview, we had so
many downloads we had to put a gate in
front of it and then people found a
around the gate, but now it is publicly
available for everyone to try and and
and give it a shot.
But I don't want this to be a half-hour
pitch for Kiro. You can do this process
spec-driven development without Kiro and
there's a few few ways.
One is that you
basically have to just you can do this
manually with anything. You could tell
the your assistant, your large language
model to include the following. First is
the user requirements. You would tell
them please based on XYZ create a whole
set of user requirements. Now, you can
feed it your own user requirements
beforehand and say, okay, use this as a
basis or you can have the editor or the
AI IDE
go ahead and create it for you.
Then you look back and forth and make
sure it's okay. Then you tell
the assistant to create the design
document.
Then you look back at that and then you
have it create the implementation
details. These are the the tasks list,
the tasks one by one to actually
implement it based on the requirements
and the design document you created. So
you could do this kind of a manual way
if you like.
I'll give a shout-out to Spec It. This
is GitHub's open source way of doing
this process. You can install it in a
variety of different coding assistants.
Now, in Kiro, you have this lab This is
the IDE version. We have plan mode
inside the CLI if you prefer the CLI,
but in the IDE you would choose spec.
And then you would go ahead and give it
a prompt. So, in this case I could say
like build a movie MCP server to keep
track of movies I've watched or build an
a movie website, whatever you want. Now,
you're probably thinking is this spec
only good for greenfield brand new
projects? And I would say absolutely
not. I've seen existing apps that are
years old have dozens and dozens of
these different spec files in them. And
this example, it's kind of more of a
greenfield, but you can definitely use
it for existing legacy projects as well.
It thinks it works very well.
And I would just say that these are
really good for when you're doing
in-depth features, when you need your
project needs a little more upfront
planning, uh and you just want to build
things in a structured way. For
definitely works really well with
complex projects.
We actually added a spec mode for bug
fixes, too. So, you can use it for
smaller things, though you may want to
just kind of vibe code those things
instead.
Here's what our requirements document
looks like. So, in the first part it
creates this uh requirements phase where
it's in this ears format and it gives
you the introduction, like the
requirements, the user stories.
Uh we also have a process where it asks
you questions beforehand. And so, we
added in some extra question and answer.
So, as you put your prompt in, it'll ask
you some clarifying questions before it
creates this requirements phase. You can
also do this quick plan mode we just
added, which uh will go ahead and just
generate all these documents quickly for
you based on the questions and answers
you give. So, there's a lot of different
ways you can do this.
Then you'll create a design document,
which is a higher-level design document.
You can also start with the design
document first. Some people kind of take
this design and requirements, combine
them.
But typically with with our spec-driven
development flow, you can either start
one or the other.
And then you might have mermaid diagrams
here, ASCII art
with all the information. Now, this is
at the point I would highly recommend,
if you're trying this at home, to stop
and go in and update it with your
knowledge and expertise and taste to
exactly what you're looking for. Because
it's only as good as what you put in.
But you'll find out that it even with a
smaller prompt it and with the
clarifying questions, it does a pretty
good job.
And course you always want to review it
for markdown the markdown files for
inconsistencies, hallucinations, and
errors.
And then finally you get to the
implementation phase. This will be a
list
of tasks.
Uh it also has something called
property-based tests in them, which are
tests that are against the requirements
document and design document. You can
additionally have those created and ran.
I would highly recommend it, so that way
it makes sure that the the tasks
actually are implemented correctly.
I usually also, uh quick tip here, once
it creates this task list, I tell it,
"Please take the top four tasks, put
them at the top, and create an MVP for
me first." So that way I can actually
see it working. And then I'll implement
them I'll implement the MVP version
first.
Now, I love model context protocol. I'm
not going to go into exactly all the
details of it, but it's a way
essentially for your model providers to
connect to different data sources. So,
in this case, I'm using Kiro,
and maybe I'm using like OpenAI or
Anthropic,
and we want to connect to different data
sources.
So, we have this MCP protocol in the
middle,
and it connects everything together for
us, which is awesome.
Now, I get this question, "Isn't MCP 6
months old and it's dead now?" Now, a
lot of people on the internet have
opinions that change every other day,
and some people were saying that, well,
you can do a lot of stuff with MCP just
with command line tools. I really think
MCP is still maturing. There's a lot uh
a long road ahead for it, especially
with some of the security stuff it's
doing. I would keep an eye out for MCP,
but one of the main reasons I like it,
especially for the Spec Driven
Development Flow, is you can have
something like in Jira or Asana, all
your tickets, all your
uh
large requirements docs, and then you
can have it being pulled into your Spec
Driven Development Flow when it creates
your specs, which makes it much easier
to work with. So, if you have a product
manager that has actually written
a requirements document, you can pull
that in.
And uh it just makes a little bit
easier. And I'm I'm talking about any
any kind of project management service.
And grab technical details for it.
You can also put additional rules in
your steering or your agents.md files
that tells it, so if you're using Spec
Driven Development Flow, make sure you
grab the information out of this MCP
server. And that way it knows where to
look. Or you can just specify it in the
first step, like, "Hey, look at this MCP
server when you create the
requirements."
So, let me show you a quick demo. This
is the latest version of Kiro, the IDE
version. And let me give you a a quick
show of it. Now, just for the sake of
time, I don't have time to actually go
in and create a brand new project from
scratch, but I used this one. It's a
movie database. So, this is more of a
green field, brand new project, but I
think you'll still get the idea.
I was in the spec mode here. I said,
"Please create me
a movie website." So, what it did is it
started with this design document. And
this case In this case, I actually told
it to start with design instead of
requirements. And then this shows the
actual
preview of the
markdown file. So you can see it created
a bunch of different mermaid diagrams
that show the architecture of it. Gives
you sequence diagrams. And so I went
back and forth with this and updated and
edited and it created this all for me.
If I scroll down to the bottom
of this document it created, you can see
here it created a bunch of property test
tests.
And these are really special tests. It
uses fast check in this TypeScript in
the node world to do these tests which
actually run dozens if not hundreds of
times with different values to make sure
that
it's uh these requirements are satisfied
correctly, which is really nice.
And then it created this requirements
document in once again this EARS format,
so it's really uh very simple with these
user stories, requirements. Uh let me
see if I can open it up again. Here's it
in preview.
Uh so here's the requirements document.
Requirements one, movie data loading.
When the application initialize, the
filter engine shall load. So it kind of
gives you step-by-step exactly
what's uh what it's doing here.
And then when I went back and forth with
this, I got to the task list and I asked
it, "Hey, in the task list, can we
create like an MVP?" So it went ahead
and updated the task list and even says
right here, "Task one through four
deliver a working MVP, browsable movie
grid with search, genre filtering,
sorting, and the full 80s synthwave
theme." So it actually redid all the
requirements and to get this
uh basically MVP up and running out of
the door, which I really enjoyed. I went
ahead and just implemented all of them
after that, but you could see how it
works. You can also see it created this
property paste based tests,
which are nice which I can go back in
and take a look at the execution. You
can also, let me see if I scroll to the
bottom here. Here it is. So if I just
kind of hover, it shows like a little
bit of information about the
property-based test. Like with property
test
test for genre filtering for any movie
data set and if the extracted genre list
must
contain exactly a sorted set of unique
genre. So, it tells me exactly what it
did at this point. So, if you want to
learn more, you can go to kiro.dev or
you can join our Discord at
discord.gg/kiro.dev.
I highly recommend everyone watching
check it out and make sure you connect
with me on LinkedIn at Eric Hanchett.
Love to just connect with as many people
as I can and also on Blue Sky at Eric C
H or
X. Thanks.